this is my first big award show so I'm
just sort of playing it cool and
observing everything you know I'm just
gonna enjoy it while it lasts because it
may not last forever apparently anyone
recognizes me unless it's like a bunch
of school girls or something then it's
like
Wildfire one says it to one girl and
they all go oh yeah I know him but but
you know an agent told Leo to change his
name to Lenny Williams because they
thought Leonardo DiCaprio was too ethnic
relax
race is in 45 minutes well Leo not Lenny
got his first acting Credit in 1979 in
an episode of Romper Room a decade later
he landed a gig on the new Lassie his
paycheck 414 dollars a day after that he
appeared on shows like Roseanne
Parenthood
and of course his breakout role on
Growing Pains I almost got the ones
without the happy hog but they were kind
of Stuffy I come in as a new character
this year and you know it would be hard
adjusting but I mean Big Show big people
big they've been with each other for so
long you know I didn't know how they
feel about me coming in but they were
really nice about it you know the whole
Hollywood scene isn't exactly my kind of
you know I don't know give me a fancy
word it's not exactly my thing I don't
like uh to schmooze and all that thank
God I wasn't a TV Idol I was on Growing
Pains for a year thank God I can move on
and be respected as an actor and not not
have been set in that
as the Public's mind frame is a series
actor or a Teen Idol or anything like
that because it's not something I want
to be Leo's first big feature film was
This Boy's Life starring opposite Robert
De Niro how big is turkey gonna be but
who did he want to impress yeah mainly
my best friends and what they think
about it probably who cares about
everyone else you know
um you want to take this Johnny next you
start alongside Johnny Depp in What's
Eating Gilbert Grape I'm not sorry I
think people nowadays want to see good
films and this is definitely a good film
that's
that's all I could really say that's
when Leo scored his first Oscar
nomination no oh God
yes you know I'm just so happy to be
here I got your standard that's the
backswing like that and then you got
your Forge fin he quickly became a
household name but his biggest supporter
Mom ermelin oh she's flipped out every
couple weeks I'm in a new magazine so
they she sends it to our grandparents in
Germany and they flip out my whole
family
[Music]
from the set of the quick and the Dead
with Gene Hackman 2 hanging with Mark
Wahlberg on set of The Basketball
Diaries we were there best friends right
boys
she's great
he's cooler I don't sing I don't dance I
just act behind the scenes of Romeo and
Juliet E.T captured this moment Leo
trying and failing to keep a straight
face while kissing Claire Danes
oh my God are you a romantic guy
um
yeah I'd say so you know when I'm alone
with a girl I'm you know I'm doing the
baby voices the whole thing all that
ridiculous stuff what's the most rubbing
noses and all that stuff yeah of course
king of the world um
is that the term never live that one
down um being an actor is something that
the only sure thing that I've always
known throughout my entire life so it's
given me so many more opportunities and
so much more than I could ever hoped for
that it's completely worth it Leonardo
camera
can't get away from us this is insanity
isn't it are you a little impressed
though this is definitely the biggest
Premiere I've been to by far blows
everything else out of the water
absolutely
1997 everything changed for Leo Titanic
banked one billion dollars at the box
office and launched him into heartthrob
status give him a wave Leo come on you
got it we are going crazy
do you ever get used to this full scene
no I don't think you can at all I'm
actually still blind I can't still see
anything it's like a series of flashes
it's always surreal man always
completely surreal foreign
it's all about stirring up you know
attention for your film and the media is
crazy out here you know all over the
place it's pretty nuts but you know
you're here to support your movie
as an actor that's what you what you
have to do
fans got a double dose of Leo when his
two monster Hits Gangs of New York and
Catch Me If You Can we'll release back
to back in 2002. people are going to be
surprised
that they see this remarkable range in
Leo DiCaprio all of a sudden well I can
say to that is thank you very much how
do you feel about the two films having
to compete at the box office the truth
of the matter is that I you when you
throw a film out into the world you
never know how people are going to
receive it making a western gonna call
it the outlaw he starred in Scorsese The
Aviator and got an Oscar Nam and a
Golden Globe win as The Eccentric Howard
Hughes so how late will you party when
it's it's yours to celebrate I don't
know I I have I haven't eaten a single
thing all day I have a pulsating
headache right now because it's the most
surreal weird experience I've ever had
in my life and it's it's a fantastic
feeling though ultimately it really is
even though the heart is beating and
you're almost faint it's a good feeling
yes yes I feel great I mean this movie
you know is a film that I wanted to make
for such a long period of time and to be
awarded like this is uh it's never
happened to me before so it's amazing
next up the departy certainly with you
know actors like Jack Nicholson uh
playing opposite him you really never
know what to expect but I you know for
me it's a it's a dream come true you
need to really come with your A-game
fans watch Leo's big screen
Transformations he was a mercenary in
Blood Diamond a mysterious millionaire
in The Great Gatsby then false teeth a
ball cap and toupee plus colored
contacts turn Leo into a 77 year old J
Edgar Hoover do I kill everything that I
love but no matter what he did on screen
the world was always obsessed with Leo's
personal life and do you foresee family
marriage for yourself in the future sure
absolutely absolutely
and keeping the paparazzi at Bay not to
get the baby's face photographed right
well I don't have a baby so I don't even
know that yet I'm talking about in the
future and you're still too young
the list of Leo's ladies is long and
includes Gisele Bundchen bar rafaeli
Blake Lively and now Gigi Hadid but he's
always been fiercely protective about
his private life first of all I have to
know who you brought tonight is your
date
um me myself and I
Leo's mom is often his plus one like the
night he took home the Golden Globe for
The Wolf of Wall Street you gave birth
to that man yes you do good work thank
you thank you my parents thank you for
supporting my my entire life I love you
more than anything I love the fact that
you thanked your mom and dad you know we
didn't have much but I had parents that
said look our son wants to do this this
is his dream and they drove me every day
to auditions and they supported me and
none of this would have been possible
you know I I lived in Los Angeles but
Hollywood always felt like this elite
club that I could never belong to and I
mean they kept with me even if I didn't
get a job for a year they they
reinforced my dreams so you know they're
special people
it's somewhere between six and nine
kilometers across okay now if you're
crunching the numbers Leo's movies have
raked in more than 7.3 billion 10 of
them were up for the best picture
Academy Award he was nominated six times
himself and finally won best actor for
the Revenant to tell stories like this
is has been my dream ever since I was I
was four years old and who could forget
Leo's on-screen Bromance with Brad Pitt
in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood and
Brad thanking his co-star at the Golden
Globes um I also have to thank my
partner in crime LDC he's an All-Star
he's a Gent and uh I wouldn't be here
without you man I thank you I would have
shared the raft
it's pretty humbling it's uh I feel
lucky is what I feel I feel lucky to be
to been an actor that's been able to
work for this long
[Music]